a while ago we talked extensively about
WikiLeaks and I told you that I believe
WikiLeaks was acting in the interests of
Russia and of the Trump campaign during
the 2016 presidential election and
campaign that took place I made it clear
that it's possible that WikiLeaks and
Julian Assange didn't know that they
were receiving documents from or in some
way furthering the interests of Russia
in a pro Trump way I gave them the
benefit of the doubt as a reminder the
video has now been removed but Julian
Assange was once asked in an interview
about this he said our source for the
leaked documents about the DNC our
source is not a state party so the
answer for our interactions is no when
it comes to whether Russia was their
source now of course the way he worded
it I believed was significant he said
our source is not a state party which
could mean two things that it is someone
that is working on the behalf of Russia
and feeding information to WikiLeaks
it's also possible that WikiLeaks just
didn't know who their source was and
they claimed not to know who their
sources were and that's why I was
doubting this attempt at separation
between Russia and WikiLeaks WikiLeaks
that Julian Assange attempted which is
on the one hand WikiLeaks maintains they
don't know who their sources are but at
the same time they were saying our
source on these leaked documents
definitely isn't Russia well if you
don't know who your sources are how do
you know who it isn't that was weird
we now have a blockbuster bit of news I
mean total total bombshell that blows
the entire Trump Russia story wide open
US intelligence officials number one had
previously identified the intermediaries
that Russia used as a sort of conduit to
get information to WikiLeaks but we now
actually have connections proven
connections that WikiLeaks was in direct
contact with Donald Trump jr. direct
contact with Trump jr. the contacts are
interesting not necessarily because of
the degree of coordination that existed
I'll talk about that a little bit but
it's most interesting
because it completely eliminates any
doubt that WikiLeaks was acting in the
interests of Russia and of the Trump
campaign let's start with this tweet
from Donald Trump which released it this
was released by Donald Trump jr. okay
and what basically happened is that as
soon as this story broke yesterday he
kind of tried to get ahead of it by
showing the chain of messages that he
had with WikiLeaks and the first one
that I have on the screen here it asks
it's the WikiLeaks Twitter account
asking Donald Trump jr. to find out
about the website Putin Trump org and
Donald Trump jr. replied to WikiLeaks
saying he'd look into it okay no big
deal
WikiLeaks suggested to Trump jr. later
that they confidentially leaked a year
or more of Donald Trump's tax returns to
them sort of WikiLeaks becoming more
bold in their request to Donald Trump
jr.
and WikiLeaks pitched this idea of hey
everybody's talking about your dad's tax
returns what if you leaked some of the
tax returns to us the way WikiLeaks
pitched it was as follows where they
said hey Don we have an unusual idea
leak us one or more of your father's tax
returns if we publish them it will
dramatically improve the perception of
our impartiality that means that the
vast amount of stuff that we are
publishing on Clinton will have much
higher impact because it won't be
perceived as coming from a pro Trump
pro-russia source which the Clinton
campaign is constantly slandering us
with let's keep that up just just for a
moment Pat so the defenders are saying
that this account is not admitting that
they are a pro Trump pro-russia source
they are saying very clearly the Clinton
campaign is slandering us with being a
pro Trump pro-russia source but look at
the earlier part it will improve the
perception of our impartiality so this
is there are people who are seeing this
in saying there's nothing to see here
it's merely WikiLeaks acknowledging that
they are seen by some as a pro Trump
pro-russia source but that they're
really not this is language that makes
it very clear that they are asking
Donald Trump juniors help to take
attention away from the growing
realization that many had that they are
functioning as a conduit to ideas and
leaks that would benefit and did benefit
both Russia and Trump also the WikiLeaks
account suggested to Donald Trump jr.
that if it doesn't go well on election
night for Donald Trump that they should
contest the entire election as having
been rigged make a big stink about the
election results and ultimately Donald
Trump won but still pushed the entire
rigged election narrative saying that
three to five million people voted
illegally for Hillary Clinton that he
who would have won the popular vote in
addition to the electoral vote had it
not been for a rigged election with all
these millions of people voting
illegally or twice or being bused here
or there and that is exactly what Russia
wants I've said this before it's not
specifically about Trump wanting Russia
Russia wanting Trump rather Freudian
slip there it's not specifically about
Russia wanting Trump to be President
only or exclusively because they think
that Trump will pass laws that would be
good for them a lot of it is they saw
Trump as the incompetent manipulable
fool who would create chaos he would
throw the American democratic system
into chaos and potentially even D
legitimize it period and that's why
Russia would have an interest and would
have this idea of saying hey say that
the election was rigged which is exactly
what Donald Trump did after winning the
electoral vote but of course losing the
popular vote in November of 2016 when I
read the original story about WikiLeaks
asking Don junior to tell his dad don't
concede if you lose the first thing I
thought of was when Donald Trump said or
refused to say I will definitely concede
if I lose he said he would evaluate it
and that just rings so true to what it
was that WikiLeaks was suggesting that
they do and then we come to the example
that really shows at least to some
degree that the Trump campaign was
playing ball with WikiLeaks on October
12
of 2016 the WikiLeaks Twitter account
asked Donald Trump jr. to have Donald
Trump senior his dad tweet about their
new John Podesta email leaks and 15
minutes later Donald Trump did exactly
that
Byron tau from The Wall Street Journal
pointed this out on his Twitter account
he actually put up the side-by-side from
the report about what we've learned from
WikiLeaks and Donald Trump's eventual
tweet and only 15 minutes after
WikiLeaks suggested to Donald Trump jr.
that they tweet about these leaks Donald
Trump sent out a tweet saying quote very
little pick up by the dishonest media of
incredible information provided by
WikiLeaks so dishonest rigged system 15
minutes 15 minutes and this was
effectively similar to what we saw with
that meeting with Russian lawyer Natalia
vessel Mnet's kaya in Trump Tower two
hours after Paul Manafort and Jared
Kushner and Donald Trump jr. met with
the Russian lawyer in Trump Tower the
meeting where she came promising
incriminating dirt on Hillary Clinton
Trump took to Twitter and tweeted it
Hillary how long did it take your staff
of 823 people to think that up and where
are your 33,000 emails that you deleted
just hours after the Trump Tower Russian
lawyer meeting WikiLeaks is simply not
an unbiased clearinghouse of information
they are very very far from that and
this isn't a value judgment that I'm
making right it's not an indictment of
everything that WikiLeaks has ever
released all this means is WikiLeaks is
a partial actor that worked during the
campaign to further Russian interests
visa vie trying to get Donald Trump
elected you can interpret that however
you want you can make whatever value
judgment of that you want but it is
beyond denial at this point and I would
add I want to remind you that Trump
appointed CIA director Mike Pompeo
previously testified that WikiLeaks is a
quote non-state hostel Intel
servus we now have clear communication
between this non-state hostel
intelligence service and the
presidential campaign of the current
President of the United States that
escalates the current investigation
being carried out by Robert Moeller
significantly and the major takeaway
that I have for you is do not be tricked
into sort of understating the
significance of this Donald Trump jr.
received a suggestion from WikiLeaks and
went directly to Donald Trump and Trump
did exactly what Assange or WikiLeaks or
Russia wanted him to do
Trump complied with in 15 minutes and
tweeted out a promotion of WikiLeaks
latest John Podesta releases there is no
point at this that there's no way at
this point to credibly argue that Trump
senior had no idea and I am warning you
now the write and Trump jr. they're
writing this all off as nothing but it
is not nothing this is evidence of
WikiLeaks and the Trump campaign
coordinating via Twitter direct message
they are saying hey listen we turned
everything over they being Trump jr. in
his attorney we turned everything over
so therefore there's nothing to see here
which is a fallacious argument right
that's like saying I didn't hide the
fact that I murdered someone therefore
there's nothing concerning about the
fact that I murdered someone it doesn't
work ok and what's next is Oh Donald
Trump jr. he was a low-level unpaid
part-time volunteer for the Trump
campaign he wasn't authorized to speak
to WikiLeaks on our behalf in any way
the contacts mean nothing whatsoever and
the response from Assange is riveting
Julian Assange put out a series of
tweets where he said to begin with I
cannot confirm the alleged DMS from
Donald Trump jr. to WikiLeaks WikiLeaks
does not keep such records and the
Atlantic's presentation is edited and
clearly clearly does not have the full
context do you understand how in the
same that statement is they don't keep
records but Atlantic's presentation is
edited if you don't keep records are you
just going from memory about how the
conversation went how is that even
remotely credible then Julian Assange
went on to say WikiLeaks loves its
pending publications and ignores those
who asked for details Trump jr. was
rebuffed just like Cambridge analytic in
both cases WikiLeaks had publicly teased
the publication's thousands of people
asked about them Assange went on to say
WikiLeaks can be very effective at
convincing even high-profile people that
is it is in their interest to promote
links to its publications which of
course is kind of thinly in a thinly
disguised way saying yeah it wouldn't be
a surprise if we convinced Trump to
tweet out about what we put out there
and then lastly Julian Assange tweeting
WikiLeaks has such hutzpah that it
allegedly tried to convince Trump jr. to
leak his father's tax returns and his
own Russian lawyer meeting emails he did
WikiLeaks appears to beguile some people
into transparency by convincing them
that it is in their interest although of
course it is WikiLeaks that lacks
transparency saying on the one hand we
have no records of these communications
but we can tell you that the ones that
have been published aren't accurate and
lack context on the one hand they say we
don't know who provides us with the
information that we release but at the
same time they say but we can assure you
that it wasn't actually Russia and this
is part of a long list of contacts with
WikiLeaks from the Republican Party we
know that court congressman Dana
Rohrabacher
met with Julian Assange offering a deal
to potentially absolve him we've learned
that Cambridge analytic I reached out to
WikiLeaks and offered to organize their
hack emails we also know that Cambridge
analytic is part of the Russia probe
investigation and then from the Paradise
papers leaked
remember those covered them last week
that confirms that this Robert Mercer
used dark money to fund his efforts to
sink Hillary Clinton's campaign and it's
all being written off as some nothing
burger even though we are now able to
connect dots that we didn't even know
existed
we're living in a historic moment right
I mean it's sort of axiomatic to say we
are witnessing history of course we are
everything we witness becomes history
but I believe that what we are seeing
right now is going to become
a very notable part of American history
at some point in the future and you know
fortunately the real Patriots aren't
getting distracted by this they're busy
defending accused child sex assault or
Republican Roy Moore but we'll talk
about the latest allegations they're
coming up a little later send me your
thoughts about this I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership